Well.
Well,
well go to your mom's house,
Christina
first.
We're not
to finger spell it.
Yay.
Aye.
Nay
Nay.
Jina nope.
Nope.
You're going to sign the to live long and prosper,
uh,
facing forward you a couple of times.
So again,
Ay
ay
Ay.
Okay.
That was Ramsey.
It's really good work.
Totally amaze.
Really special.
The tank,
t I n t
s t a.
And T.
I really like her.
All right.
Um,
you ready to open the show?
What the clip that you wanted or do you want a different one?
Um,
you surprise me.
I don't know.
Okay,
here we go.
Let's open the show
with me.
Here is air for Fineman.
Who is honestly the world's first student body president who identifies as
gender non binary.
Don't bring in one loving to this.
Well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Uh,
yeah man.
So this was on fusion fusion TV and um,
this is fantastic.
Yeah.
This a first student body president and it's non binary.
I was hoping the president would come out as nonbinary.
What one of my favorite parts about this nonbinary um,
you know,
yeah.
Is when you get to see people talk about it in interviews.
Yeah.
And really when you,
you can really start to appreciate the nonsense it is.
Um,
because this person essentially just as like,
oh,
it's just feelings that day.
Yeah.
I like to see what the argument is.
She looks like a her and I don't want to presume,
well,
you know what,
you should make presumptions,
which is a mouthful.
And maybe some people don't know what that is exactly,
but luckily we didn't have you to explain it.
So Erica,
tell me a little bit about yourself.
What does it mean to be gender nonbinary?
MMM.
Means that I don't really identify as a man or a woman.
It's somewhere in the middle,
but where in the middle of the fence on the day.
Yeah.
Wait a minute.
I understand.
Identifying somewhere in the middle.
Okay.
I've heard of people,
you know,
I go,
okay,
but then what?
How does it change?
Oh,
you're here.
Find out.
That's the part.
I don't get it.
His eye,
you know,
err more towards a feminine side or I like to present more femininely,
but there are other days where I fall more in the middle and then a little more
on the [inaudible] side.
Like for example,
today I have men's pants on,
but I also have my hair and makeup.
You mean like everybody?
Everybody in the world that,
what do you mean?
Everybody in the world?
People,
men and women err towards one side or or another from a data.
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
yeah,
you might put more makeup on and address one day and you might feel especially
feminine and the next day you might wear a tee shirt and jeans and then,
but does that mean that I'm identifying more mass male,
masculine on a certain level you are or aren't?
I am.
Yeah.
That means,
wait a minute,
we've just discovered that I'm not,
oh my God,
I'm non binary.
Binary.
Oh my God.
This whole time I've been so confused.
I think,
by the way,
I know there's some people listening that are shaking their head.
I think you deserve the full mockery of what you're going to get because this is
utter and complete nonsense.
Yeah.
I,
you know,
are not different.
Everybody from day to day can feel more feminine or mastering.
I agree.
If I feel as though throughout my day I switch and,
but then I don't demand that other people address me by my proper pronouns.
Not An asshole.
That's what,
that's the problem is that the demand that the external world match the internal
world that you refer to me as my chosen pronouns.
Yeah.
Hold on.
I'm a zero now.
Yeah.
So does she go full heat?
Who it that they,
they,
I dunno.
Zim Will,
let's zero it up a second.
It's kind of finding a way to exist outside the binary and really have fun with
the performative aspects of gender,
the word,
you know what all that is.
I learned that as an Undergrad in philosophy,
the performative aspects that these are all fancy words for like what it looks
like is what she's saying.
Performative aspects of the
academic talk.
I'm going to start saying that in interviews.
Yes.
Whenever I say that I'm really into the perfect performative aspect of gender.
Oh,
gender expression.
You have to use that phrase
formative,
but the performative aspects of gender
that is 100% academic nonsense that nobody in the real world understands
performative aspects of gender.
Yep.
Right lady.
I remember in philosophy they would say like the discursive reasoning and you're
like,
well,
there's no,
what does that mean?
There's no track that gets more bullshit language and philosophy.
Well,
yeah,
we're pretty good at it.
Yeah,
I definitely,
I remember I read a book once on ocular centrism,
which meant that because we all see the world through our eyes,
that there's a bias towards the eye.
For instance,
you would say,
ah,
I see what you're saying,
or do you see what I mean?
Ocular centrism and that's somehow a bias that we need to overcome.
Why do we need these less class that I tried to read your friend who was an
author and a philosophy teacher,
like a page of his book,
but I realized that it's because I don't have the brain,
the capacity.
I did not know what the fuck he was talking about.
I don't think it's your brain that's deficient
in the bubble of academia long enough.
Yeah,
that's true.
They all speak the same bullshit language.
And that's what,
this is an unfortunate,
uh,
product of the academic,
the ivory tower,
the system that tells you everything is validated,
everything is merited and warranted.
And I think this is dog.
She was a bit of attention to,
this is how you're different.
They're like forced to version of the,
of you being different.
Can I tell people are like,
I'm from Taiwan.
That's interesting.
And then she walks in and goes,
I'm kinda nine binaries.
Yeah.
It's an identity.
What?
Well,
you're from Taiwan.
You thought that was cool,
right?
I'm nonbinary.
Or it's like,
Hey,
I'm,
I'm golf or I'm Greg.
Or it's like what?
What music used to be the,
can I tell you why?
I think it's kind of bullshit cause on that's deep bro.
I put a put a very sincere,
sincere call out there asking for a nonbinary person to come forward and talk
about it on that team.
I'm really curious,
like enlighten me if I'm wrong,
if we're off base here,
if I'm behind history and not one person has written to me,
has thousands of people and a lot of people listen to that show and every time I
put a call out,
hey,
do you live off the grid and I'll get like 10 off the gridders or is your,
were you in a cult?
I got,
you know,
eight people who were in cults.
So it's like this,
this thing is a little not true,
you know,
and it's not ringing true.
The way that you identify goes way beyond what you were taught to me a little
bit about how you feel in your own skin.
I don't think she knows how she feels.
I'm sorry,
day.
Quite a bit of depression.
When I was trying to figure out who I was.
That was something I was really hard to experience of gender dysphoria,
gender dysphoria,
such low self confidence.
Wait a minute.
Gender Dysphoria,
is that what I'm going through?
You might be going through it right now.
Oh No.
I am identifying as female,
but I have a dysphoria about this.
W and I met people,
they,
them pronouns.
Something clicked and I was like wait,
really was so legitimizing and natal legitimizing legitimate.
That's another academic word.
Write that one down.
Legitimizing.
They love to use that in academia is the thing that
I heard they them pronouns.
I got to get on board.
That's what they said.
You and I met people who use they them pronouns.
Something clicked and I was like,
wait,
but don't you think?
And this is going to sound really stupid and I admit it's just cause I don't,
I'm ignorant.
Yes.
So save the angry emails but isn't,
it isn't.
She's kind of confused about her sexuality.
Even though sexuality and gender are two different things.
I understand.
Isn't she really just a lesbian?
The gender and sexuality are two different things.
Just the pants and then sometimes I'll tell you why.
Cause most lesbians I knew in college kind of look like her,
you know what I'm saying is maybe,
maybe the marine be their real identity crisis is like,
do I want to go between the,
between the,
yeah,
the vagina.
The butthole.
Cut It in half.
I mean it could be,
right.
Maybe she needs to lick a few Virgenes and then she'll figure out her agenda.
I did.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I mean,
how are the two not,
I don't know.
There's to be a,
there should be a lot more snickering amongst her peers and they're all
passively accepting what is fucking total horseshit and incense and staring
down.
You could tell them to no,
this is great.
They're like,
I have to accept this.
That's because if you don't,
and the academic world,
you're considered a totally irrational.
I know you're a fucking neanderthal.
Yeah.
Dummy redneck.
I,
I tell you,
there's not been a lot of push back on us for,
well,
I'll tell you Jean,
I went to pro.
No one's pushed back on me making fun of it.
Oh,
it's so dumb.
I went to uh,
a Yukon,
so I was in academia.
Yeah.
And did they ask you what your Pronoun was before you took the stage or asking?
Very disappointed.
I had a great time there.
And you said so you were very pleased.
I was.
See the thing is people don't realize they,
when you do colleges and it's students only,
it is a bit of a,
you're stepping into the unknown.
Yeah.
Because academia is this like imagine doing stand up to that crowd I just showed
you.
They're very repressed.
Yes.
And it's very oppressive.
Very offended.
Usually by a lot.
Yeah.
So and like I'm not,
yeah,
the Cray,
you know the most offensive dude.
But you know,
I'm a,
I'm a club comic.
Aye.
Tour.
I performed for adults.
So you always have that moment right before you hit a college stage where you're
like,
is this going to go downhill?
Well,
and,
and I've had situations where they told me beforehand,
you can't talk about sex.
You can't talk about religion,
can't talk about drug.
You can't do alcohol and nothing.
So w what we talk about baking cookies,
recipes.
Yeah.
I know you.
And it can all be taken the wrong way.
Everything can be anything.
Anything.
You pick your poke fun at this and it could be like boo.
Yeah.
If you get that whole crowd that's super,
super nonbinary.
Yeah.
So anyways,
that was really,
really happy that it was.
It was,
did,
it was fun.
And were you able to do your normal set or did you cater it?
I did the set that I'm touring with right now and,
oh,
that's fantastic.
Yeah.
Well that's very good news than you'll be had in college.
Even
for a second before college.
You go like,
oh,
that's an old,
uh,
you know,
you pull them in your brain and you go,
I'll have that on deck if I need to do something to get out of this.
Yeah.
I didn't have to do any of it.
That's a wonderful thing.
Yeah.
And I did Fsu the week before,
which was fun,
but they did the most preferable way to do colleges,
which is half students and then open to the public.
So you have an ideal crowd.
You had this perfect kids and then adults and they can,
they have permission to laugh when the adults laugh.
Exactly.
Inappropriate.
Yeah.
Quote inappropriate.
Exactly.
So that,
that was a,
that really fun.
Um,
do you know what happened?
And I didn't tell you this in art,
maybe I did tell you this in Minneapolis and where mommy apple tits.
Yeah,
I'm in Minneapolis.
It's,
so I'm on the tour right now and there are regular seats and premium seats in
premium seats come with a meet and greet.
And for those wondering,
why wouldn't you just meet everybody after the show?
It's really just because of how much time it would take.
So they,
you know,
do a select number of seats and they go,
these people can do a meet and greet.
So I've had that in every city.
Um,
almost nobody used their meet and greets in Minneapolis.
Yeah,
I dunno.
I think from what I heard or from what I saw,
like people tweeting at me,
they didn't know that it wasn't that,
that they just didn't know they were entitled to.
We had a lot of laughs about it and then everyone was like,
nobody wants to meet you.
Um,
so what happened was,
and also they accidentally oversold them.
So second show,
Saturday they go,
you have 87 meet and greet.
So I was like,
whoa.
Because normally they try to keep it to 50.
I met six people after that shit.
I go,
okay.
So Minneapolis,
it's just,
no,
uh,
I,
I don't know what the,
obviously with the confusion was there because in every other city it's been
completely fine and normal and New Orleans,
Atlanta or Clearwater Tampon,
Milwaukee Ma,
it worked normal in every city except for Minneapolis.
That's weird.
Yeah.
They weren't informed.
But the shows were really fun and the whole weekend was really fun.
I had a lot of people asking me,
Mike Cronin is bone snake three on Twitter and he killed it and the first
weekend was Carlos Valencia and he fucking killed it.
So really good time.
Really enjoyed,
uh,
those both legs of the tour and uh,
yeah,
I know there's some,
and it's like a new city every day.
So crazy.
Yeah,
it's very tiring.
It's exhausting.
Yeah.
What city did you,
what'd you like the best?
What did I like the best?
I was too hard to say.
It's too hard to say.
I mean
all the shows have been fun really.
There,
there hasn't been like a bummer show.
Thank God I haven't been to the southwest yet.
Have you for the decor?
I go but I haven't been for a show yet.
No.
What are you going to do when you have to go to southwest?
Will that,
will that make you not like it?
I don't know.
I'm thinking of getting a Bolo Tie and uh,
you know,
getting the,
the denim buttoned down with a Bolo and that's not a bad,
the dentist,
not the bad part horse.
Um,
I dunno.
Maybe I,
should I rock that from my Albuquerque if I do Albuquerque?
Of course.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that'd be fun.
Yeah.
That's neat.
Your dad called the other day and he was taking a shit as
we were facetiming him.
Yeah.
He didn't hang up.
Did he know without shelter,
by the way?
Taking a public shit?
Yeah.
That wasn't at home.
I didn't know that.
He was like,
I think shifts here all the time.
And he just kept talking and know and I'm like,
do you want to hit?
And he was like,
oh,
check it out.
And he was like leaning and wiping.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Cause we were,
we were on the way to the mall,
which has become our favorite new thing to do.
And you were talking about how your dad is so good at being married that he's a
personality type,
that it's a really good fit for him.
He loves marriage.
We were talking about like what would happen if one of my parents died first and
I think,
uh,
I think my dad might talk more of a game of like,
you know,
Oh I would meet people and date and stuff,
but no,
also,
Yo,
we pointed out that much like you remind me there's no woman that could tolerate
no,
you're disgusting at this point.
Now Your Dad,
because your dad probably would date a few people just to break that in prose
post-marriage nut off,
you know?
Huh.
It's been 40 years with the same woman or whatever.
Sure.
So he'll probably do that.
But I just see him as a creature of habit.
Yeah.
Like he wants to have the everyday comfort that marriages like a warm meal,
a clean bed.
It's so weird.
I can't,
it's funny when when you talk to people whose parents been together this long,
you came and picture anything.
Like I would have tried to picture it.
I can't even wrap my head around it.
And being a dating or just being alone,
just
no date.
Like how he would function with another person,
you know,
is also it.
You get to this these later ages in life,
you go,
uh,
just everyone's so particular and they have their,
are there routines that I just,
I don't know how,
yeah,
he might try to recreate what he had with your mom.
I think that's what everybody would do.
Yeah.
You know,
and he'd be like,
just make my coffee baby.
Yeah.
Cause they have their little rituals.
Routines that,
yeah.
The other good night stuff.
I know.
Oh yeah.
She rubs his back or something at night with the,
with the [inaudible] this is a thing.
Yeah.
And,
and that's what they do is like kits,
the lights at like nine.
And she was like,
can I read my iPad?
And he's like,
ah,
I kind of bothering me from that too.
She's like,
I have to sit in the dark.
Yeah.
That's why I love,
that's how you and I are though.
Cause I,
it's lights out for me at nine 30 and then you're watching the movie full
volume.
Oh my God.
You guys turn it down years.
You're like lab,
you always have,
it goes down,
down,
down.
I had it on volume the other night and you go cute tearing the analog.
Well cause you're watching violent stuff.
It's always explosions and guns and me please.
So we go to,
uh,
we have our routine now.
We've joined this new country club called the mall and we go all the time,
all the time.
Now before we had a kid,
you and I would do the crate and barrel weekend trip and that was a big part of
our day.
That was real exciting.
But it was always just like a window shopping.
And mostly I would be,
oh well yeah,
that,
oh,
that would be cool.
The strawberry Huller and aren't those glasses nice.
Yeah.
And we would just kind of dream about owning all of the stuff at Creighton and
we still don't have it.
No.
And then,
uh,
we had a kid and now when you have a toddler,
you got to take that kid out every day.
Yeah.
So it can't stay home.
Those of you that don't know,
it's been raining in Los Angeles for like six weeks.
Right.
And also so we used to do,
I mean we still get to hear them all crying.
Everybody's crying.
Who's covered in snow,
right?
No,
but I mean it's not at all normal raining,
raining,
raining nonstop.
It's like the northwest.
So,
you know,
sometimes we go to the park,
but anyways,
with this weather we started going to the mall.
We do feel like we joined the mall going in the club.
Well now cause we park,
we used to park in front of Nordstrom and that was our jam.
We have that entrance.
We know where to go.
Midwest mom now is our jam.
You know,
I really enjoy it.
It's my jam.
Even saying that to you lately that I became a Midwestern mom.
You're,
you have like such a mom when
I'm way cool.
I'm the coolest mom there is.
She's,
I'm a cool mom.
Well,
I noticed that.
I've been saying,
I say awesome and I give a thumbs up to staff religious thought by super lame
from my God.
But if I say awesome sauce,
I know that's the death of me.
You've said that's my jam.
A lot of that is my jam,
but I've been saying that since the nineties I feel like that is my jam.
Okay.
Anyways,
anyways,
here's the thing about having them all membership.
You do kind of feel like you joined a club because here's why would somebody,
okay,
you join a club for a few reasons.
If you were to join a country club,
right?
First you have somewhere to go right.
Check that box every day.
It's nice.
In other words,
it's clean,
it's clean and it's warm in there.
I used to look at,
yeah,
check that box.
Yeah,
they have a food options.
She had a cheesecake factory.
We started parking near the cheesecake factory.
There's a place inside of Nordstrom that cafe.
We like that you want to feel special,
indulgent something.
Check the inbox Mrs. Fields.
Absolutely.
And so it becomes a routine and you go,
that's where I'm going today.
Going to spend our hour thing is too little jeans.
He likes,
um,
continuous movement stroller.
So that's the other thing is you have miles of,
of,
you know,
real estate to walk in indoor walking.
Especially when it's raining
outside.
He likes that.
That'll chill him out.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean you can't go to the park.
You got to do something with that kid.
He can't stay indoors all day.
Can I say in house rather than this other thing you've been doing a lot lately
is really price checking and like,
well because we've been hanging out at the mall at the time and now he started
buying more things that you don't need.
There you go.
Well you don't need it.
His mom,
she goes,
how much stuff do you need?
And I buy a pair of sunglasses,
half a pair of sunglasses
and not taught like that dog.
Like I want another pair.
Let me go.
I don't know,
$200
sunglasses.
I went to writing and I got 12 pairs for 200
you want me to show you?
No,
I just want to get these.
You want to talk about it?
He's not too much money.
Maybe that's a lot of money for sunglasses.
Are you crazy?
I'm like,
I sold out nine shows.
I want to get my sunglasses
so much.
There it is.
Perfect impression of you.
It's not how I talk.
The other day you wanted to buy fancy glasses but LJ was having a meltdown and I
said,
well we'll hold off.
Let's left.
Come back tomorrow.
That's all I'm saying.
Yeah,
we're going to be there tomorrow.
You can pick out your shit later.
Yeah,
it is expensive.
$200 for sunglasses.
It's ridiculous.
Who does that?
Barely.
Barely,
barely.
That's a lot for us.
For Plastic and that Luxotica we've seen the documentary.
Tom,
you want to see what your code cost?
No,
no I don't.
I know I got you a nice just because present.
I know,
but I,
what did I tell you?
Take it back.
I get very guilty and I don't like it and I get really weird about it.
No,
you shouldn't.
He know that I don't accept gifts or love or kindness for easily my gut.
That's why FIFA and I are buddies were both shelter dogs.
We're both,
we're both,
you know,
we always think that this is our last meal.
A Nice coat though.
Did that.
You did.
Thank you.
You love it.
I love it.
It's beautiful.
It's a,
it's a life peace.
The life coat.
Yeah.
Like I said,
he goes,
this is this,
this is one for your collection,
this collection.
I go,
okay,
the rest is the gap.
This is my gap collection.
You're funny because you definitely are like that though.
Since the,
since we started dating,
you've been like,
uh,
I got this TV 89,
um,
then you should get a new one now.
It still works.
You just turn the knob and then she's got to move the ears and you can watch
anything.
You know.
It is that communist upbringing though,
because we didn't,
I didn't,
I wasn't raised that way.
The American way.
You just buy stuff like,
yeah,
I just held on to shit my whole life.
No,
I know.
It's just upbringing.
It's communists.
Yeah.
You get in the bread line.
I hope it all works out.
Help me get a banana.
Yeah.
Maybe.
Maybe one orange this month.
Yeah,
of course,
man.
But here's the thing.
When when the nuclear holocaust comes,
guess he's going to fucking survive that shit because of,
because of my communist upbringing.
I'm bread for tragedy.
I'm bread for the emergency stuff.
I'm telling you all this top talks.
Got me too excited.
I got it.
I got to dial it down something.
Hello,
my name is Allen Gonzales and I'm the radiation specialists here,
Berkeley nucleonics.
Today we're very excited to introduce one of our latest innovations here at
Berkeley nucleonics or Sam Mobile,
one 50 you're at Berkeley nucleonics.
We offer a wide array of instruments,
pagers to handheld survey meters,
Ah,
to portable ice tub identifiers.
Now Banana find critical matter radiation system.
The Sam will will one 50 comes standards,
a newborn baby.
They're large.
So I picked that up yet the texture,
if you do require neutron,
we offer two options.
Okay.
Healing and three and a solid state.
And you're trying to to her in for that added sensitivity.
We all,
you can also
large volume,
I believe.
How boring
he's stammering.
So smart.
Yeah.
Isn't that crazy?
Just to even consider how smart this guy is.
Oh my God.
I mean this guy's capacity to process the information in about this product is
so beyond,
this is really a,
a brain thing.
Like,
you know.
Yeah,
no,
no.
This is an intelligence level cradle.
You Shit.
Yeah.
I mean he's boring as a box of rocks,
but yeah.
But my God,
now,
do you think if Anthony Hopkins got this dialogue,
you could make this exciting?
Yeah,
I think he could.
I think anything I was going to make anything extra.
He really can.
He was so great.
Heard of a fucking movie.
Yeah.
So social
solace,
I think it's called the Sam mobile one 15 utilizes our stairs.
VR APP peak with Picos new algorithm.
You can easily
identify it,
determine whether it's special nuclear material,
industrial or even medical aid.
How much money do you think he's going to move that?
Attach a photo,
how much money and send it back to your reach back.
It's very strange.
Jack reacher around,
he saw the movie,
we saw that movie or reach or reach back.
We've seen nothing but turds either watching shit.
Well the problem is we don't have much time.
We have to like choose quickly,
but there's not a lot of good options on the movies,
flicks or iTunes.
I know,
man.
Yeah,
we saw in Fart.
No.
Which is the same guy that Did da Vinci Code.
Dan Brown Vinci load with Da Vinci load is um,
you know,
as,
as really popular book.
It sold,
I don't know,
hundred million copies.
You read it.
You liked that book.
I thought that that book is a fun read.
And here's what it is.
It's,
it is like perfectly accessible,
uh,
foofy mystery,
thriller type.
And it has like enough interesting bits and he writes everything.
Cliffhanger.
You know,
it's,
it's a writing style,
but the end of every chapter you would go,
I got to read the next year.
Yeah.
So it's so good.
There was like,
there's just a style to that.
Right.
And there's just the way that he writes and just a fun read.
Really captivating.
That movie was fucking dog shit.
Eventually load or the load was dog shit.
And they find the load at the end of the,
and the end of the,
the,
the movie,
what it is is Da Vinci's great.
Great,
great,
great grandson comes all over Tom Hanks face and he goes,
that's what my great,
great,
great granddad wanted to tell you.
And that's the meaning of the Davinci load eventually load.
No.
Wow.
That movie I cannot believe performed that well at the box office because it is
a fucking pile of shit next to that book.
Then they had uh,
angels and come demons and then in Fart,
no.
Came out.
And did you see angels and calm?
I think I did.
I think I did no Audrey tattoo in it because she probably,
I don't remember.
I don't think she was probably in a second.
But in Fart,
no is like,
it's more of the same.
It's kind of casual,
like it's,
it's something you can just kill time with.
Right.
Watching.
But that's what we look for at the end of the day.
We were hanging out with baby jeans all,
you know,
you're tired,
you don't want to focus.
So that's why we've been picking these kind of dopey movies.
Yeah.
And someone fart now.
I fell asleep about 20 minutes into yeah.
And it was no good.
And you're saying it's all right.
It's not that bad.
I mean it's not,
it's big budget.
You know,
they have good actors.
That goes a long way as we've noticed that
dog shit.
It's um,
it's tough to sit through some of these folks.
We,
we,
so we rented solace with Anthony Hopkins who is the god of acting.
That's so good.
Yeah.
But they cast the supporting actors that were just not great then that was the
carry their weight.
A big thing that stood out about jack reach around to reach all the way through
all the way back is that the whole supporting cast were like terror turds,
like fucking local one o one actors.
They were just like not good.
And all these guys,
the supporting actors in in solace were terrible.
Terrible.
Plus the check that's supposed to be the cop.
She was super blonde and hot and her clothes were too tight.
Like she wore like the,
the button down.
But it was so tie in,
her pants are so tight.
I was like,
oh,
so distribute buddy in that movie.
You had to think that this is going to be a big hit.
I think about that.
Well it should have been,
the script was good for neutral thriller.
Yeah.
And the director though,
that's what ruined it.
I think he ruined the movie.
I think so too.
I think he,
uh,
I think he put his calm and the shots,
like I tried to do too much and you know what I really hate is the shaky cam
where they make it like,
ah,
so actiony it's a floating camera and that it's like bouncing behind the couch,
up and down.
So the couch comes into frame sometimes,
but then he would cut to from that to another camera that's clearly on sticks.
Just picking up the side of the profile.
And you're like me being consistent about that point.
I remember watch,
there was one scene between Anthony Hopkins and the other guy,
the supporting actor and half the fucking frame is the couch,
the cushion,
half the fucking shot.
You want to see a bad movie?
Dammit.
Solis.
That's what it's called,
right?
Solace.
Solace,
yeah.
Let's see.
Solace.
But I liked the idea of it.
I liked the,
you know,
the paranormal or the,
I liked that he's an intuitive and he could solve crimes with using his psychic
powers.
I liked that kind of stuff,
you know?
But yeah,
so fucking lame.
That's not a good movie.
Jeffrey Dean Morgan,
he's the guy that,
uh,
started Jeffrey Dean sausages.
He's the guy that plays the actor.
Jimmy Dean May.
Oh No.
Yeah,
that's the whole foods plant.
that's Jeffrey Organic.
He,
um,
he has all the sausages and he gives him away premise of it as a nonprofit
sausage.
Yeah.
Organization.
And the chick is,
I mean,
she's lovely to look.
She's very pretty,
but it was so like,
bitch,
you ain't no cop.
Not,
not like the cops I've seen in La and he was two,
he didn't look like a copy there.
That's weird.
And I fell asleep through that one too.
Yeah.
This,
this was a man and then we were looking at,
we were so desperate that we even considered a vin diesel movie and it had a 13%
rotten tomatoes,
one three 13% approval rating.
So,
and I thought,
well,
this,
this has to be the dumbest thing too dumb.
Here's a clip.
The same moment.
One 50 can adapt to a wide array of applications,
whether it be a sporting event or even a large radiation spill.
Sam Mobile,
one 50 will fit in your vehicle.
And your boat or even in a helicopter,
a large surveying areas.
I don't understand why.
There you go.
That was super boring.
Thank you for sending that.
This,
the Super Boarding San Mobile,
pretty easy to repurpose that poor guy that had to do this thing.
I know you realize that that was,
that's the best,
most outgoing speaker in that department.
That guy extrovert.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
that,
that remember how fucking witch hunter,
is that what it was called?
Hunter.
That's the Vin diesel movie.
And I thought,
you know,
I've never watched a vin diesel movie.
Amaze.
We'll give it a try.
He can't be that bad.
He's,
you know,
he's in everything.
Oh yeah.
It's called the last witch hunter.
It's exciting.
That's not it.
I like is I,
I,
you know,
I can tolerate then diesel if it's a good enough movie.
I liked that movie with the Rock.
The one or the big earthquake happens.
Yeah,
I saw that in theater.
I laughed so hard.
It was really funny.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Michael Caine's in this,
my fair share of it.
This thing is 10 million views.
Your story.
End
of the accident.
Cross,
but see,
I'm into it so far.
Okay.
Yeah.
Into next
for natural.
I like that.
Hello?
Which hunter?
What's your car?
I see.
Yeah.
This is already lost to me
now.
I want to see it really well be hunted.
Get it.
There's witches and then there's hunters and he's the witch hunter.
No,
I understand that part.
This
is a shorter trailer then we saw the problem is they gave us too much movie and
your,
that's when you can see what a turn it is to trim down your shit trailer.
It could be a decent trailer.
That's true.
True,
true.
Yeah.
We saw a different one.
What else did we see?
We saw in Fart.
No,
we saw solace.
We saw one more.
One other Turd.
Yeah.
Then you write it down.
No,
I thought you wrote it down.
Let me see.
In no vin diesel songs.
There was one more that we saw.
No,
no,
that's it buddy and fart now.
Sorry.
Fifth.
Yeah,
and foreign.
It was not that bad.
Honestly.
Watch deck Chloe Kardashians show awhile back.
I honestly,
that was better than everything.
We just talked about,
I'm not a huge herd ashy and fan,
but that revenge body we watch was okay.
It's like people getting into shape to get revenge on somebody,
but ultimately they discover that they should just do it for themselves.
That's a great concept.
Yeah.
We should get,
we don't have a series to get into.
That's the problem.
I know.
And there's actually,
yeah.
Too many out.
That's the other thing.
It's overwhelming.
I feel like every time I go on Netflix now I see 25 original series and I'm
like,
what?
How do they,
I don't know how to get it cranking them out.
Right.
And the thing is that there's like super good quality shit on Netflix and then
there's like totally Rancho de Movie,
lifetime movie of the week stuff on there.
We were like,
wait,
what?
Whose quality?
Controlling this shit.
I know.
It's there.
So weird stuff on there.
And then there's like great stuff.
Speaking of ups that show the,
uh,
the one that Chloe did.
Okay.
Um,
how does,
it kind of reminds me of the fab battle that I had with Bart and a,
I've extended the fat shaming to our president.
So,
um,
just like so many of you fat shamed myself and burnt Chrysler.
Uh,
yeah.
And it worked though because we,
we,
we both got motivated.
Yeah.
Um,
I'm hoping to extend the same favor to our medically obese president of the
United States,
but I'm doing something really nice.
I am donating all of my profit on the Trump is fat shirts
to charity.
Very nice.
The starlight foundation,
so,
oh,
wonderful.
There it is.
Uh,
Trump is fat.
He is very fat and he has suits don't fit him well.
Yeah.
He,
well,
he's doing something.
It's a,
it's a fat guy
move.
I know all the fact that it moves.
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
dark suits,
big cut.
You tries to obscure.
Oh,
you're,
you're pear shaped,
but he needs all the tricks.
Taylor a little bit maybe.
Yeah.
And he can afford it.
He's just,
um,
he's trying to,
he's trying to act like he's got his,
you know,
his skinny jeans on.
Yeah.
But he really just needs to drop some weight.
He is very fat and for the sake of the country,
he should be losing weight.
That's all I'm saying.
Big Old Fatty.
Um,
yeah.
So get one and uh,
you'll see they get one.
You just go to [inaudible] dot com.
Click on the store and you'll see the uh,
I'll make a big thing when,
um,
you know,
when we've sold the get done selling them,
we're going to donate the proceeds.
Um,
exciting.
Yeah.
I'm doing this starlight foundation.
It's a charity for a terminally ill children.
Oh Wow.
That's pretty good.
This was surprising to me.
I didn't expect the president to come out with this,
but he
good afternoon America.
I told totally.
Let's get straight to the point.
Yes.
I told you I was bringing your jobs back to America.
Yes sir.
Yes.
Am pregnant and jobs back to America as you will see a mountain.
I'm in the shit with you.
As you receipt rec have already be gone.
We call the last every neighborhood twit near new PVC pipes.
We will have no PVC pipe.
Where in your neighborhood.
So American girl fall in love,
swamp nannies and I guarantee we got a whole lot of most stick become.
There you go.
That's a little Trump.
Those trav nineties I didn't know that's what he was saying.
Little Trump nineties yeah.
What's that?
That's,
that's his handle.
Oh,
okay.
On Twitter or just
what?
Because he goes,
hey,
that's how it Kinda how he says.
Yeah.
And I didn't know that he was actually saying a little Trump nineties and
that's,
yeah.
And it's L I l t R U M P nine zero apostrophe s.
It's okay.
No,
I think it's La here.
I'll tell you.
It's a little Trump.
I don't think it's an apostrophe.
S is it l I apostrophe ll for low level?
It's,
no,
it's,
it's um,
it's l I l t r u m p nine zero s [inaudible] nine zero s okay.
Okay.
I mean that's,
that's what I've been able to pay.
If you want to support little Trump nineties,
he's on Instagram.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's it.
You got to know a,
you got a little too Maktoum low friends,
honey rush.
These are watching him for monks.
The lushly jewel for snitches,
and I told my friends over there,
we got some shit.
We meet you in the flow.
Yes,
thanks to my friend Tony Calling the people chattering.
David once told me,
don't get your hands too close to the top when you fee because they could take
the skin.
Well after you failed in less than a couple of steps
I made you look at this.
Give me a tiny moon and ma'am,
I need you to go look Trump names and give me some names.
Okay.
I don't know what the name,
how.
Thinking back to smaller one in here.
We've named him being Sochi,
but I don't know.
It doesn't seem to be off on Nana could give us some names.
We've already infiltrated little Trump nineties yeah.
Fat
Bird is fat Chrysler from Russia.
All right.
His wig is right on though.
His Wig.
His,
yeah,
his outfits just totally right.
You have to go to just so you can get,
if you have only this guy,
you definitely have to get a loan with him.
Yeah.
The whole joke is the look.
He looks fantastic.
What jokes,
right?
Oh,
sorry.
I'm sorry.
Ah,
little Trump nineties.
Well,
Trump.
Yeah.
Well Trump,
he's doing his thing and stuff like that.
Why the nineties?
I wonder.
I have no idea anything was happening with this man.
We build a wall.
You're going to keep the motherfuckers out.
Uh,
I dunno the motherfuckers out.
Yeah.
Um,
so this was submitted as a vocal fry clip.
You know,
we were always,
you know,
participated in,
in um,
highlighting a severe vocal fry.
Um,
where's one of our great vocal fry guys is of course a,
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Steven Segall and also the guy from the swinger show or whatever.
That is so incredible.
That's a,
what does that show again?
The poly by show.
That's a polyamory.
Yeah.
And he's like,
ah,
two girls,
uh,
back guys.
This is,
this is the most vocal fry I've ever heard in a meeting or actually maybe in a
human,
I don't think I've actually heard a woman this level.
Well,
Megan and I have been together for nearly three years.
She's a beautiful girl who I am very much in love with.
And I have a lot in common with,
I can't wait to get home and jump in a pool.
That guy,
by the way,
is basically a murderer without a weapon.
He is a world class Muy Thai fighter.
Um,
champion in,
I forget what category,
but that dude,
that's the funny thing is you hear this voice and you're like,
fuck this dude and that dude would kill you.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
Your hands is that he's not a sissy.
This guy can be the opposite.
The opposite.
Let's go in the pool.
Now.
How about this guy?
This guy has appeal voice to the pool.
Thoughts wanting to control them.
I don't know how to put it.
Uh,
uh,
assessed them permanently and that's why you kept them all right.
Right,
right,
right.
Oh,
that's your favorite Jeffrey Dahmer?
Not my favorite.
Which one's your favorite?
I don't have a favorite.
He's got those cool sunglasses.
I mean they cold glasses.
You liked it ever really cool glass.
It's got cool hair.
Cool glasses.
Yeah.
Really cool.
Jeffrey Dahmer?
Yeah.
I want to say I was living there when they got him and where?
Milwaukee,
I think I lived there when they got them.
How's it [inaudible] 93.
And uh,
as my obsession grew,
uh,
go,
it was saving body parts such as skulls,
skeletons.
Uh Oh,
he really fessed up to that.
Yeah.
You seldom hear them really fess up to it.
So he must be proud of it.
I don't know.
They don't really,
they don't ever admit sometimes.
I mean at least,
and I was the shows you forced me to watch
the killers go.
Why didn't really do that?
Or they'll admit to like one or two things.
Yeah,
I killed my mom,
but this was one statistic.
One of the,
yeah,
no,
that's a process.
It doesn't happen overnight.
Uh,
when you a nice hair,
you personalize a another person and he was in as just an object and the object
for pleasure instead of a living,
breathing human being,
uh,
it,
it
seems to make it easier to
do things you shouldn't do.
What part of this was funny?
I was just pointing out the vocal fry.
Next clip.
Thanks a nice,
we've figured out Jeffrey Dahmer has vocal.
I'm so happy.
Let's highlight this guy more.
Can we know he's a horrible person.
He's dead.
How is he?
Yeah.
When did he die?
Oh,
a number of years ago.
He was beat to death in prison.
Oh good.
Yeah.
No,
that's excellent.
Beat him with a broomstick to death.
Good.
That's a vicious beating.
Sure.
As well.
Some of the stuff he did was pretty vicious to right.
Uh,
yeah.
That's uh,
that's uh,
yeah,
it says here,
Jimmy Dean sausage,
Jeffrey Dean Morgan sausages are a free team working.
Um,
and then Morgan Stanley sausages to Morgan Stanley sauce.
he was killed in [inaudible] 94 all it's been a long time ago.
Are you sad that day when you found out?
Fuck no,
that guy was horrible,
man.
Let's see.
Uh,
just cause I can remember it now.
He was arrested in [inaudible] 91.
Okay.
Fif is sleeping in my arms.
Yeah.
But the trial maybe happen then later the sea trial began and [inaudible] 92
January [inaudible] 92.
Okay.
Uh,
was real to be sane,
not suffering from mental illness.
I don't know if I'd agree with that.
I'd say he's suffering from mental illness now.
Fif is so cute.
Look how he's sleeping on me right now.
That's a really hard time.
I know he is the kiss easiest person in this house.
Yeah,
I'm really cute.
I'd say actually Betsey's Kissy or than Fif.
Like she demands the kisses in the morning.
She rams her head and to me and she's like,
pet me,
pet me.
Have you had any beef?
Does it too,
by the way?
No.
Just so I'm clear.
I was there then that year.
Oh,
that's too bad.
You missed each other.
I was a little young for him.
I think we moved there in seventh grade.
Wow.
Yeah.
Well you guys could have been BFFs.
Could of could have gone to the mall with him.
Yeah.
Huh?
Do you think fif misses you?
He loves me.
He loves you.
He's Super Kissy.
You,
however,
not very kissy.
Why do you say that?
Well,
I just said lately that I've been kissy or towards you,
like I demand in the pets and the kids is like I'm sweeter to you and then
you're just kinda like you kind of an alone dog.
Like you kind of look out the window.
Like I would say if we're doing a
rundown no of the house of who's the Cassius.
Yeah,
we include everybody.
Go ahead.
Okay,
so we'll say most kissy at the top.
That'd be bitsy.
She's the CAHSEE yesterday.
Yeah.
Second most would probably be FIFO.
But he's a distant second in a way.
Cause she's well to her,
she's so affectionate.
She so sweet.
All this.
He really does demand the pets and loves all she wants.
That's all she wants.
Yes.
Then no,
then you're not kissy at all.
Your Anti Kissy,
you're Jeffrey Dahmer.
Kissy Kissy Kissy.
He's like fuck out of here.
Yeah,
little jeans.
he is.
Lj does not,
I mean I he to come home rates the,
he comes up to you sometimes if he's tired he'll let you squeeze them,
kiss it.
But most of the time he's like,
fuck out of here.
Okay.
I got to walk.
I got some shit to do.
Okay.
Is that normal that our son just like doesn't want the kisses?
Yeah.
He says that's his first word.
It's so weird as fuck you.
You're like,
wow.
Fuck Outta here.
Assholes.
Yeah.
He's speaking Spanish man.
Yes.
No,
I think it's normal.
Right?
What?
The toddlers that age,
they're just like,
Ma,
they don't know yet that he doesn't know what she sees her.
Awesome.
Yeah.
But hearing not as a function as I am.
I'm the,
I'm the affection champ.
Debbie.
Ella.
Yeah.
Take that one finally.
Wow.
Barely.
See,
that's what I'm saying.
You're just not like the Nike's me sound cold.
You're cold fish.
No,
I'm not.
It's like being married to a cold fish outta here,
so not kissing.
That's not true at all.
That is not true.
Um,
uh,
this is an amazing
drive through.
Oh,
I'm excited for him.
by the way,
thanks to everybody that got the,
hey mommy.
Thanks jeans shirt.
Uh,
we appreciate your support and I'm a lot of people ordered them assets on it.
No really fun to uh,
you know,
come up with these and see what,
what people respond to and it's a very,
very,
very high quality shirts.
So I think you'll all be happy with that.
Good one.
That one really was a phenomenon.
Yeah.
Hi Mommy.
Thanks jeans.
I had no idea that it would take off the way it has.
Its starting to something you and I just did as a joke for years.
Yes.
Super Fun.
We never thought to share it with the listeners until recently.
I know.
Just so funny.
So funny.
You.
Anyways,
we'll check out with this guy.
He orders at a drive Thru as my dad.
Hello.
Hi.
Hey Buddy.
It's top dog.
Aww.
Can I get a steak?
Chalupa supreme.
Just the Chalupa.
Uh,
can I uh,
I love to laugh.
Can I tell you a joke?
How do you know that a fax was sent by a blonde?
How do you know what that a fax was sent by a blonde.
I don't know how to,
you know,
it's got a stamp on it.
I love to laugh.
That's it.
Thank you.
Bye Buddy.
I love you.
That is.
Oh Wow.
Where are you talking about creative to the umpteenth level.
Yeah.
That was brilliant.
Massive.
That was fellas amaze.
I can knock it over and I love to laugh.
He does.
Fuck.
I just,
I love to laugh.
The whole thing about his jokes was all though he just like,
I love to have a good time,
you know?
Yeah.
Okay.
Does though he,
you know,
your dad is seldom in a,
a Sullen mood.
That's true.
I would say he's the personality champ.
You really,
he's cut off this breath.
It's just so
God damn fif pressure teeth.
The soap as well.
Like a sewer.
You got to get that fish market.
Yeah.
You got it.
You got to get that to him.
He just yawn.
Wafted up to my face.
Tommy,
would you marry your dad?
Yeah.
There it is.
Eh,
asked him,
will you ever date your mom?
Okay.
That is the dumbest conversation between two people.
I've taught me.
Would you marry your dad?
There you go.
I asked him,
will you ever date?
Your mom
wants to know why he calls me mom.
You know what I mean?
That's terrible.
That's a terrible
Danimals.
Danimals great.
Yeah.
That,
that forever ruined stamina for me.
Now I have to really always think about it.
Danielle.
A mall.
Yeah.
Dan.
Mama stay animal standing at my,
uh,
I love blonde jokes by the way.
Some broad,
broad
money.
That's so perfect that he did that.
How do you know if you're in front of a Polish firing squad?
I think that's true.
Uh,
the guns are faced at the,
uh,
Guy,
Dad,
dad.
Do you not understand how these work?
You're not supposed to actually try to answer them.
He always does.
I know.
He tries to guess the answers.
Oh my God.
When I spoke with him the other morning,
he goes,
Hey,
Christina,
audio like it,
the country's being run by all white guys.
Really?
Yeah.
He,
he was,
he knows I'm super,
you know,
lefty,
California.
He thinks we're all crazy.
It's so funny.
He tells me all the time.
You didn't know it.
Now you know why I'm so crazy about,
yeah,
yeah.
It was done.
I,
yes,
I understand that.
I love you.
I know.
I get it.
You get it out.
He said that to me.
Now you're ina 90 mls.
Do you understand why I just love Tommy so much.
That's such a cute little shit.
Dammit.
He used to say to me,
daddy car me Gargan me Daddy.
Just pick me up with Spanish.
I learned that.
Yes,
dad,
it's amazing that he's been with a Spanish speaker for 40 years and he doesn't
really beautiful Spanish.
Yeah.
This speaks absolutely the most elegant and gorgeous Spanish.
Hmm.
It's really moving.
Is that what you
cause that's how I
Garg may daddy card of my walk a block and you'd say Cargill May,
you know,
we have to do is have him speak Spanish for us next time.
That would be really a fantastic,
yeah.
We should have him just read some common Spanish phrases.
He'll be like,
uh,
tango.
I'm bright.
He says how?
He says,
Eh,
maybe the dangle I'll break.
Your dad is so,
um,
he just hates adapting to any other culture.
It's so interesting that he married that and he just hates like the traveling
thing.
Yeah.
You know,
like he doesn't know.
He doesn't want to see any other country because like it's,
it's inconvenient.
Right?
Is that,
is that what it is like,
yeah.
He can't watch this convenient movies.
Does that expression a lot?
Yeah.
I'm all about convenience.
Yeah,
yeah.
I get it.
But you know what?
The older I get,
the more I'm like,
oh yeah.
Why leave?
Why leave the country?
Forget it.
Yeah.
Why leave the fucking house?
Everything's here.
He,
uh,
yeah.
I,
I've been like,
you know,
I don't really want to go to Ellie.
Pretty Sad.
Yeah.
Why don't you want to go to Italy?
You know,
you're walking in a museum.
See the painting.
All right,
Saad.
Wow.
It's
very inspiring and talk to you about this.
I mean,
yeah,
you see it all right.
I saw it.
That's what he said.
I think my dad's the same way though.
Like he only goes to certain kinds of countries like the Philippines or
Thailand.
I mean for the culture.
But like,
he wouldn't go to a Europe now for culture or the,
either he's over it.
He's like,
ah,
fuck that shit.
The only place he hasn't been,
that he wants to go.
Um,
and this is like a stretch,
but I think he,
you know,
he's still considered going.
Is England specifically your dad?
Yeah.
Oh my doubt.
Never go London is there like us to speak English?
I'm like,
yeah.
Okay.
Yeah,
he likes it because they speak
English.
Everything's smaller though.
It's still Europe.
I know he wouldn't like that,
but my dad is also a history buff so he would love to go Churchill's bunker and
shit like that.
I mean there's not a World War II show he has not indulged in,
in the last 40 years.
So yeah,
I think he would enjoy it.
I you,
he might actually enjoy going is Berlin cause it's Hitler Shit crowds.
I don't know.
I mean I don't think maybe maybe Berlin Wall,
you've got Hitler's bunker but it's uncomfortable to travel with him cause
because you sense how unhappy he is and the food's weird.
The catch that doesn't taste right.
Yeah.
And it's like he's the kind of person,
like he doesn't sit still.
He kind of like,
yeah.
Moves back and forth,
you know,
change.
It,
puts the left leg,
the crosses over the right,
and then 30 seconds later he moves right to left and then left to right and then
right to left.
And you go like,
you're right.
And he's like,
yeah,
you've moved a lot in the last year.
And he's like,
yeah,
you can comfortable like,
okay,
he,
and it's bad.
I mean,
that's a small example,
but it's,
it's that in everything.
And it goes like this.
He goes,
yeah,
he crossed his arms,
he crosses his arms,
moves the,
uh,
the forks and the knives.
He lines up the forks and the knives,
just them a bunch.
And then you just sense that he's,
um,
he's always kind of like a,
basically like you ready to go?
Yeah.
It's always the next thing.
Like he's always ready to go on and do the next thing.
Not to see.
That's misleading because it makes us sound like he's more adventurous.
The next thing is when are you ready to go back to the hotel?
He wants to get back to home base,
which I understand it,
but he's a,
he's an extreme version of it because,
you know,
I get that way too.
But he's,
he's basically like,
you leave the hotel and he's like,
when do you want to come back?
So like travel with him is just,
Oh my God.
Really?
A lot.
Yeah.
What does he like to do in the hotel?
Um,
what are we missing
when he's gone?
I think it's where he just feels at ease.
Yeah.
Say his,
he lays down,
but he still wears his Khakis.
No,
expects them off in a hotel room.
So his boxers,
Oh yeah,
I've seen that.
Boxers and shirt socks and he's got Turner classic movies.
Just go through the channels or some news or something to eat and you go get
something to eat.
And then like,
as,
as his last bite is in his mouth and as you might have a few more,
he was ready to go and you're like,
I'm still eating though.
And you'll,
and then he goes,
okay,
like my,
sorry,
I'm sorry about that.
And then you see him like just kind of looking around the room,
like how many more minutes to meet?
You're like,
can we like really dial it back here?
And we really just ease into this.
He's got nothing to say.
You know?
It's not like he's boozing and
having a good time.
He's,
yeah,
he's all business.
He's like,
well,
let's get in and get out,
man.
He's also just board.
Yeah,
that's what he told me.
He's told me that before too.
He doesn't like talking to people.
He's like,
you know Sheena,
I just,
I don't like talking to me and people,
people bore me.
You know what I mean?
They warned me like,
thank you for telling me that.
He's told me.
He's like,
yeah,
I go,
you know,
my friend was saying,
blah,
Blah Blah to you.
And he goes,
he's boring.
I go,
can you pretend
just for like the sake of you no decency and to make somebody feel like they're
not boring.
Yeah.
I like to do that.
He walks away mid conversation.
Oh yeah.
I've seen him do it at parties.
He did at one time.
It cousin,
cousin.
Jeanette's,
um,
when we were on that boat where the sensory fort hat,
it was right before this and sunny fort and we were talking,
he and I,
and I saw him walk away from countless people.
I think he's in his own head when he does that,
it's just super in his head,
you know?
Oh,
I respect it by the way.
I respect that too,
because what I do feel like I am a version of my yes.
So,
but the thing is,
yes,
usually with those things were all a toned down version of it.
Like in other words,
he's a 10,
and I'm a five.
And since I recognize it because it's in myself,
when I see it,
I,
it,
it's more enraging to me,
you know what I mean?
Because I actually do it and I go,
that's why it unnerves me,
you know?
And you've had it done to you your whole life.
So when you do it to somebody else,
it's like,
oh,
I,
I fell into that trap.
I fucking did that man.
Did that.
Yeah.
My Dad's pretty callous with people too.
I remember,
um,
when my dad and I were at my mother's apartment cleaning it out when she died
and my mom got a phone or my mother's phone rang and it kept ringing.
So he picked it up and it was one of her friends,
you know,
and uh,
and my dad just goes,
ah,
he just dead.
Okay.
Got To go,
bye bye.
And just hung up on this woman who was like,
that is brutal man.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
she's dead.
how did he die?
I don't know.
I'll get by and just like hung up on this.
You imagine being that person.
Wow.
I know.
And I know who it is and I like,
I never called her back.
I should've just fucking called her back.
I have a daughter after her father.
I,
cause I have so many other things,
you know,
cleaning up the place and the well,
and the thing and I that was like,
this is number millions,
unless their shit,
when somebody dies,
call that one person that called while we were cleaning out the apartment.
That's an ice cold dads and a lot of ways,
you know,
uh,
both of us do.
Yeah,
that's,
but that's why you and I are so kissy towards our son and why we're so kissy
towards each other and our lives are different because we know how,
what a bummer it is to be on the other end of that.
Yeah.
The receiving end of that animal shit.
What's up everybody?
All right.
You good?
At least your dad's like,
I'm entertaining and he can
kind of plug in.
My Dad's just like straighten narcissist,
you know,
just no one else's needs register ever.
No one else exists in Israel.
Just my dad.
It's his world and if you're not catering to it,
he's got no interest in you.
Just know Andrew,
even Ellis,
he's like,
I go,
do you want to come over and see Ellis?
Ah,
maybe in 40 years when he's doing something,
he's not going by though.
Like five times.
He told me,
he goes,
I can do more in a four or five years.
Right.
That's what I'm saying.
He feels like he shouldn't even visit because the kid's not like entertaining.
I'm using him
speaking of super healthy,
but uh,
health.
Yeah.
I started doing pilots.
You did?
Yeah.
You saw my trainer.
I did.
And what's the verdict?
The verdict is that shit's hard,
man.
Hard as fuck,
Huh?
Yeah.
Here's the thing I've done.
I've done cross farts.
I've had personal trainers,
different ones.
Yeah.
Boxing class.
I've done all those and a,
and I got the thing where I go,
I want to,
you know,
I hear you talking about it and I go,
I've always associated in heard of pilots [inaudible] as um,
pilates.
Uh,
like a female check workout.
Said you kept talking about I'm going to try it.
So I went over to your,
your trainers place or studio and did a workout and fucking kicked.
All right.
Well cause uh,
cause I'd come home from my workouts with her and I'm like,
dude,
I did like fucking prison pushups today.
I'm like,
she'll have you do it on like the side of the bar.
Like just fucking present.
Do it.
And it's hard,
dude.
My,
my muscles collapse when I'm doing.
It's really a great workout.
Here's the thing is that my God,
right heart in a workout especially,
you know,
you get married to doing the same thing.
It's totally different and if you've never done it,
um,
the focus I could say like if your focus of trying to do it is that it focuses
on your core strength,
which is for me definitely my weakest,
most peoples.
So dog shit part,
it's,
it's a,
it's a good struggle.
It's really challenging.
But uh,
it's holy Shit Brown.
I know,
I bet bad sciatica since I had Ellis and that this has helped so much because
you strengthen all your core muscles and it helps every year aligned mailer.
Do you like I'll just walk up the stairs now.
Like holding Ellis and I used to do that like 10 times a day,
two in our old house and now I just shit like I could fly up there.
By the way,
it's all endurance stuff.
Fucking blows Donkey Dick's because you'll do a set of something and you know
you're having like the resistance of these bands and do 25 reps.
So when you're,
when you hit 25 let's say you go like,
you know,
done,
and then she'll be like,
now go into the not chill and then do that.
Do it immediately.
Yeah.
Like go back to your resistance,
do this next thing 25 times and you're like,
Holy Shit.
And then,
then there's a third one after that.
So the whole,
it's just like you're continuously doing it.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's,
it's a tough word.
The thing is though with highlights is that you build your strength fairly
quickly.
Yeah.
Like when I first came to her,
I never planked in my life ever.
I don't fucking play.
Don't make me do [inaudible].
I hate it now I can do one minute,
like it's nothing.
I don't even feel one minute plank.
By the end of two minutes I'm like,
all right,
I'm uncomfortable now.
Like I don't like doing this anymore.
But I mean it happened pretty quickly too.
Like shit,
your strength gets really gets dark quick.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's my favorite.
I love on our dogs play.
Yeah.
It's busy attacking faith.
That's,
that's the plighting his face.
He's biting her ears,
tail biting.
Lots of,
cause she's the Kissy is,
yeah.
She's like,
fuck with me.
Part of me nestles demands.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
well this is nice here.
I thought you would enjoy,
boy,
uh,
this,
this is everything.
I think we could,
we could actually get into this the same way we both went to the pilots.
We can both get into this together.
Oh yeah.
Everyone has sequence,
but some are more complex than others.
It's kind of like an extension of another persona within me that most go out and
have fun.
So can you describe what you're seeing and why don't you want to do it's
ghoulish?
Yeah.
So these are the living dolls.
Oh boy.
And it appears to be men in full women costumes,
but with these,
uh,
expressionless doll face,
it masks on so that,
and there's makeup on them.
Yeah.
So it has that,
that something that maybe Dahmer would be into very alive.
Yeah.
Luck it.
It looks,
it looks terrifying.
Yeah.
It looks very ghoulish and terrifying.
I would say pup play is Lil Les Ghoulish and terrifying than this living doll.
Crap.
Without a doubt.
It is less terrifying.
This is a extremely,
I like others.
Just a gaggle of these horrifying men and these women costumes going out to a
bar.
Like anything normal.
Like it's remotely acceptable.
Yeah.
It's,
I mean,
God dammit.
Why do I have to see this shit?
Yeah,
it's that.
Okay.
Delve into the female Moscow.
Oh Jesus Christ.
A lot of social pressure to conform.
Oh,
my favorite is,
did you see when he tried to force the straw in between his doll lips and he was
like,
also there is not just a face mask.
Oh boy.
But is this like a,
there's a bodysuit on us.
It's a latex body that he's wearing over his regular body and then a bikini on
top.
He's skinny.
This bit just skinny.
Skinny.
Yeah.
Delve into the secret world of female Moscow.
Oh boy is a lot of social pressure to conform.
So what to what equate to being a person?
When I dress up and I put this mask on.
Oh my God,
Nice.
It's like a beautiful woman walking down the street.
Just scare the fuck out of everybody.
The birds are terrifying.
If you are walking down the street and you,
you're just like casually walking down and you see,
let's see this fucking night,
you think a,
a robbery just took place or was about to take place or B,
you had stepped into your own nightmare because these are absolutely terrified.
But these are expressionless faces.
Yeah,
don't move that.
Have makeup on them.
Ah,
and basically you're seeing that this is a man's build.
That's a guy wearing a latex.
Here's the thing,
if you want to pass for a woman,
then just be a dude who wears makeup.
Like try to feminize like this is just creepy.
This isn't even fuck is going on.
You look like a,
a fake woman.
Like a
put this mask on mannequin.
Oh look,
it's like a beautiful woman walking down the street.
Oh,
it ain't bro know what you see in the mirror.
I don't know what kind of women you've been looking at.
They don't look like this,
but he in his imagination.
Oh,
beautiful woman.
Yeah,
but their mounts aren't even open.
It's like,
oh,
I've heard of a woman walking down the three.
A community of men that want to look like real life dolls.
What do you see when you look in the mirror?
Are very excited.
I just want to believe that that's a 70 year old man in the mirror.
I do.
Yeah.
Have you ever not made a child cry?
Is that,
that's the first thing I think about now with a one year old yeah.
Is that he would see this and bust out crying immediately.
Therapy probably inconsolably crying.
It's so confusing.
It's even,
it's confusing for adults to look at it.
Yeah,
I'm confused.
I'm not sure what the Laura is here.
It takes you a second.
Then you're like,
oh,
I see what you did.
That's fucked up.
I mean,
I'd rather see him just like I said with a why the mask.
Just try to be,
wow.
It's so upsetting.
Yeah,
and everybody's so upsetting.
I'd rather you be nonbinary started to wear these outfits and masks.
Yeah.
Just tell me that you're a fucking androgynous.
That's fine.
Let's over your Pronoun.
Yeah.
They know that.
Doesn't this make you miss the non-binary opening cloud or percent?
Yeah,
it makes me want to crawl under a stall and watch a guy.
Shit.
That's what it makes me want to do.
Yeah.
Baseline coming out of the whole house.
The secrets of the living dolls.
Monday at 10 there's a whole series on it.
The best as her,
wait,
let me do it.
Hmm.
Yeah.
No,
it's not a good look.
Look for natural
dog.
What'd we go get a full woman right there.
Ah,
ah,
AH,
and dog.
Oh,
that's terrifying.
And we play this at this time we didn't.
Hey,
would you believe my boy,
I'm taking this shit.
I'm taking a shit dog with you.
This dude.
This kid crawls under a stall bathroom,
but I'm thinking that that look in his eye is a revealing.
He's touched.
I think so.
Either he's touched or he's on drugs.
Like he's,
he's tweaking on something and he doesn't know what the fuck he's doing.
You'd never crawl under us all in the men's room.
No Man,
that's,
I mean,
looking at them.
Oh,
no sorrows.
I actually can't believe how much this kid kept it together and laugh.
That's taken a shit.
I would,
I don't know if I'll be able to laugh with someone.
I'd be like,
dude,
I'm shitting.
I got to tell you,
Bro,
I'm shitting.
I think 98% of the population would not be able to view it this way.
I know I wouldn't.
I wouldn't either unless I knew this kid like,
well,
let's say that's the kid that's known for being a little special attached and
like here comes Ron.
Ron and visually recognizes them.
Nothing work.
They're not friends.
Right,
but he sees the kid in school because this is probably his school.
Right?
It's,
I'm assuming.
Yeah,
title one school.
But you do it.
Oh to,
I like how he says it.
Yeah.
I'm taking his shit,
homie.
Yeah.
Hey,
what'd you believe your my boy,
I'm thinking this shit.
Boy.
I'm taking this shit dog with you.
It's kind of scary because at the end,
the guy that crawled under the stall is really close to the camera.
Yeah.
He didn't walk that way.
He didn't walk towards the door.
He walked towards the right shooting and then it abruptly stops.
So yeah,
there's so much to the story.
We don't know so much.
If you could just write in and let us know if you're the guy taking a shit.
Well,
if we need to know what happens before and after the shit.
God.
I like how he laughed.
So homey.
Oh
Shit.
Yeah.
This second to shit.
Can you see the shit?
I never know.
No.
Oh.
See,
he looks either touched or high.
I think he's touched
and then no one has ever taken a shit.
Yeah,
yeah,
definitely.
I'm taking a shit.
And you know what I like too is the phrase homeboy like,
that's such an old school.
Hey homeboy.
Yeah.
You know,
it's just funny.
Yeah.
That's a good choice of words.
That's great.
Hi homeboy.
Yeah.
What you doing?
I'm taking a shit.
So,
right.
What are you doing?
Oh,
wow.
What's happening in the world?
What would you do if someone did that?
I'd be all,
I'd be so alarmed.
I would not be able to laugh.
I'd be like,
excuse me.
Um,
um,
I'm taking a shit.
Yeah.
Hello?
Like I would be frantic.
What don't you,
so I would be,
I think I'd be super,
like,
I'd be super aggressive.
Yeah.
Get the fuck out of here.
Hey.
The fuck hey man.
What the fuck are you doing?
Yeah,
I would too.
Hey.
Yeah.
I'd be like,
Whoa,
dude.
Yeah.
Hey,
the fuck are you doing?
I'm taking a shit.
Yeah.
Fucking Weirdo.
And I'd probably pinch it off and pull up my pants.
Yeah.
Probably.
You just have that mushy shit that's made your budget.
I think I would too,
man.
Right?
Yeah.
Because you're so vulnerable.
So vulnerable.
You're taking,
you're relaxed.
Yeah.
You should be.
Anyways.
Shit coming out of you.
Somebody enters that space,
a stranger crawls under the stall.
It's terrifying.
It very boundary stepping.
Very upsetting.
Yeah.
I wouldn't like that at all.
No,
I don't like that.
Gosh.
That either.
Yeah.
We have retired around this and you know,
especially when you're in a stall,
you think you're safe.
That's why you lost,
you know,
of course.
Okay.
Here's Kissy number one.
Can I see genes,
right?
Their pencils like yes.
Dogs.
However,
um,
hi.
Schnitz I saw this.
Uh,
I don't know.
Play that taking a shit homie.
Cause they're going to shit a boy.
Well you get puppies.
Why did we have a song submitted?
I should,
I feel like I should play it on the way out.
Oh,
cool.
Okay.
Young Patrion is called how eyeglass,
oh,
that's by Jeff is by chef boy.
Nice.
I'm just glad.
Oh,
we should have done this right.
We didn't do this real quick.
What's up with this?
Well Saul,
blah,
I'm in Las Vegas this week.
How's the blues?
Thursday,
the 9th of February.
Uh,
the full charge is coming with me.
Haven't done Las Vegas in the long.
Oh,
it sounds made the beat,
but I have the wrong song.
Oh,
that's,
sorry.
That's a different thing.
This is a sounds.
Made the beat instrumental.
Anyways,
thank you.
Mr Sam has made the beat official hit God.
Um,
so Vegas then I have some,
some news about some dates.
Do you mind if I talk about what happened?
Genes.
Okay,
here's what's going on.
I know details about shows that are 100% going to be gone.
Um,
if you don't know,
I'm going to Long Island Huntington next week.
Less than a hundred tickets left the next day.
Montclair 200 tickets left the next day at Atlantic city,
about a hundred.
Um,
Calgary sold out.
Edmonton had 30 tickets left this morning.
Vancouver has some singles,
so those are essentially sold out.
Bethlehem,
pa you definitely are not in danger.
Um,
then that a Foxwoods mashing and Tuck it.
That'll go fox.
What's Comedy Club in Casino?
Well this is the Foxwoods resort
casino.
That's a,
yeah.
That's how they have you promoted,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
Wilburn Boston.
The third is going to go,
it's going to be in March.
If you want to go,
you should get it now.
There won't be an adequate,
uh,
Chicago,
excuse me.
Royal Oak first has gone second,
will go soon.
Or Chicago.
You have about 200 tickets.
That's also in March.
I'm not going to add a fourth.
So if you want to go,
I would get it now.
Washington,
Dick come at the DCM.
Prov,
the original six sold out.
The seventh has about a hundred left to go.
I'm debating whether to add one to that split debating,
put them in,
put it in there and Pittsburgh.
That one's gonna go.
Same consideration is there.
Burlington,
Vermont is going to go.
San Jose sold out.
We added one more.
The big one is that Portland,
Portland is going to sell the first one went,
the second one has a few tickets left.
It's in April.
So I wanted to add,
but um,
the next day is Easter.
So I thought maybe I would come back in like a month and do an added shows end.
So that's what I'm thinking of doing.
Um,
Seattle,
you really should get a ticket if you want to go.
That one's going to be about a hundred tickets left and it's,
um,
and then of course we're doing the live podcasts this Sunday.
Very excited.
February 12th at the Irvine Improv,
the first show sold out.
So we added a second show at nine live podcasts.
We have Yoshi,
the great Yoshi Obayashi is joining us.
That is,
um,
it's going to be a totally different show.
So we're really excited about that one's close to being sold out to him.
Yeah.
How many tickets?
Uh,
probably like a hundred.
Yeah.
So I mean again,
pieces of things all have limited tickets left to them and I just figured I
would just straight up tell you that uh,
jeans,
I know you have some stuff to flood.
Yeah.
February 17th,
I'm headlining that Hollywood Improv,
uh,
Maryland Rice Cup will be joining me and some other friends to February 18th
flappers comedy club.
I'm headlining Nat,
one April 13th through 15th Brat,
the brand Improv.
May 4th and fifth fart.
Nick's Arizona stand up live May 19th and 20th in New York.
Shitty at Gotham comedy club.
I just add a Denver June one through three Denver comedy works downtown and then
June 16th and 17th man friend disco at the punchline.
Come see me.
There you go.
Uh,
Thompson [inaudible] dot com from my tickets and thousand ranch.com for
Christina's.
And um,
yeah,
we thank you guys for listening,
watching,
joining us,
ordering your
mom's house,
podcast.com.
Uh,
I think that's a jeans.
Anything else?
No,
I love you.
Oh yeah.
Amazon.
We've added the UK banner on our website.
You're a mom's house.
podcast.com you can shop Canada,
Amazon UK,
Amazon,
United States,
Amazon using our banners.
Thank you for those that have already done it and please continue to do so.
There you go.
There it is.
Thank you guys.
Have a wonderful week.
We'll see you soon.
Bye Jean.
That was all ranch baby.
To put this down.
Just slip in
area.
That's glass touch,
blah.
This is how I bless.
Good night.
[inaudible] my Arrow window flight.
I got a really bad bike.
Do you have a bunch budget?
Mariemont what's your normal Bob Dat boy?
Never head.
I'm a self trained punch honestly with my dad.
Some smell of his peers.
A sense of is as a few loads of come cause you ain't got no tail.
Put that plug in my ass.
It just like the gays.
What do you remember your dad?
You got to be coming rose bulls as a simple pump.
Jessica,
the Chemo rt Thomas in the crevice of you per se.
But you get a budget.
How much money?
I've got a really bad,
bad.
Got a really bad fight.
Come does take buddy ended at night.
Just slip it alone.
I put along here every day.
Damn Moose on his ass.
Beat you,
herb.
This is how I glad I see you did it
every year.
I'm going to drink and how you feeling about this before you hit the shower?
Get away from the P and G.
I'm not going to hammer you could shit.
After that had my
last glass
glass,
glass glass.